why do you think writers struggle with
finishing a screenplay
i think we have a lot of doubts
about the quality of our work
um i know that first draft is usually
you just regurgitate everything out
right get it out
so at every level of the writing process
you're constantly
confronting your doubts and your worst
insecurities so
i don't know it's about it's about
overcoming that and just ignore
that and just keep focusing and keep
making
marching forward so if you are
attached to those insecurities or
distraction
that stops you so that's probably why
um yeah even if even the
i i've read interviews or watched
interviews of people i admire writers
i'd admire
they go through the same insecurities
that we go through
so i don't think we ever stop
having insecurities about our work but i
think it's our job
to ignore that and just again
like a fool just marching
foolishly without questioning just keep
going
ignore the distractions and that's how
we finish
it it sounds like finishing isn't what i
could see you with finishing it you you
finish what you start
you seem very disappointed i it's very
important for me to
finish what i started um
whether it be it's not it's never
perfect like going
going through the uh baby steps
filmmaking process made me realize
screenwriting is never
ending until the film is finished so
it's never
finished and knowing that it's never
finished
it's never quote unquote perfect it sort
of relieves the pressure
to be perfect so you just do the best
you can during
that time so do the best you can and
try to finish it you have to finish it
and it doesn't have to be perfect so
yeah
so finishing isn't one of the things
that that
hangs you up is there something that's
more your achilles heel when it comes to
yes definitely finishing is not my
problem um
my problem is coming up with a concept
that i'm
passionate about for a long time see i
have a lot of ideas right a lot of ideas
come to me
but i'm attached to oh i love this idea
and then like the next day a week later
you're like oh no i'm lukewarm about it
now
so i think it's hard for me to come up
with ideas that i'm passionate about for
long
for the long term um
that's my problem committing to that to
an idea that you think
would uh would be able to um
keep you going for three months four
months your writing
that's a big problem for me committing
to that idea
did you feel that at all with baby steps
no because it's so personal
i knew exactly the structure it's a
global journey
it's an intimate relationship journey
between me and my mother
it was it was already hooked grounded in
those
two realities so uh
and those issues are very personal and
very important to me as a person
it's very authentic to my core so i was
it was so easy it's easy to commit to
that
but i haven't found anything else that's
like that i'm like
i want to hold on to you for next for
the next three or four years
maybe maybe for three months sure
it's hard to to really because you're
looking at something so closely every
day and
yeah to keep it um you know to be
interested in it's definitely a
challenge
people should just tell their stories
and see what's important to them in
their core like what's important to them
what's authentic
and those are the things that that's
going to
ground you that's going to keep you
going
when when when when the screenwriting
process is difficult when the filmmaking
process is difficult
um yeah so tell
our own authentic stories you say you're
an artist
what other artists do you admire and
either want to
sort of emulate certain work or just
just you just admire what they do
and sort of who they are i don't really
admire any particular artists because
artists are it's difficult for everybody
and
people often ask me who is my favorite
filmmaker or directors or whatever
but then it's kind of hard because
sometimes you would see this
movie and you're like oh my god so
brilliant
and then the next movie you're like uh
it's you know i'm not crazy about it so
it's
hard it's it's project by project
it's never we human beings we're never
perfect
and we evolve and sometimes sometimes
you rest
sometimes projects resonate with you
sometimes they don't
and they could be coming from the same
artist so
what i'm saying is we are always
evolving as an artist as a person
so it's hard to commit or attach
to that idea who's your favorite
you